[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast it's five o'clock somewhere in
somewhere is here edition
we are doing q and a of our 121st
non-prime livestream now it's our 121st
live stream which is not prime
quick it's our what non-prime live
stream
how many problems are they brown wow i
don't know either cheers thank you for
the drink what is it you're welcome that
is a man underboard
what's in it what's in it is uh our
finest you usually come up with great
names for drinks that's a pretty good
one yeah it'll hit yeah it'll hit you
later um
yeah it's uh mezcal
it's got a little bit of cranberry
cordial
you mean the sound the vinegar the
drinking vinegar some drinking vinegar
okay yeah it's got gorgeous different
um it's got lemon juice
fresh squeezed lemon juice uh a spoonful
of barbecue sauce
no there's no barbecue sauce and it's
everything else i said but not the
barbecue sauce yeah well now that i
taste it i do detect that i may have had
a slight mescal deficiency i i have no
doubt that you did yeah um
thank you for that yes all right
discord question this week so as you can
ask me what this is are they
well they didn't ask
am i the they know
you're not a they honey
um
that looks i'm gonna guess
that's good
that's going to be
um
cider and campari cider and campari
which looks
see the thing is to drink such a thing
you have to be manly enough to handle it
because it looks like a girly drink at
that color but the campari makes it
bitter right so it's not it's not girly
but
but it does look it
that's your usual
hard cider from um
the seattle cider you know the drier the
better and then the campari for the
bitters yeah you love the dry and the
bitter mm-hmm yeah
drawing the better that was the uh the
soap opera i was on
[Laughter]
i had a hard time getting sponsors
didn't they
yeah it wasn't a long-lived soap opera
for lots of reasons but you guys had a
lot of fun
[Laughter]
all right
our discord community
poses questions and votes on them every
week and here is the question they would
like us to answer this week
from a game theory perspective societies
with high levels of corruption clearly
favor cheaters
while societies with low levels of
corruption favor cooperators
weird countries tend to be the latter
but are they prosperous because they are
cooperators or can they just afford to
be cooperators because they are
prosperous is it a feedback loop that's
a great question isn't it though yeah
yeah um so i think you know the premise
um you know first
with a question like this you have to
i think it's important for us to say
okay there's a premise there's some
assumptions do we agree with the
assumptions i i think i do
um
right societies with high levels of
corruption clearly favor cheaters
society slowly as a corruption favorite
cooperators
weird countries tend to be the latter
those are the assumptions of the
question
yeah i think there's a built-in
that there there's something alighted in
the question which is it's not that
um
low levels of corruption are in
societies that uh favor cooperation
because the the hidden thing is that
cooperation evolved for a reason and the
reason is competition right and so
cooperation is not good enough and in
fact cooperation is not in and of itself
stable
cooperation that serves the function of
enhancing
uh competitive ability is what's stable
and so a system it is the dynamism of
the west
that comes from the interplay between
cooperation and competition
that is so productive
and so the point is it is a
evolutionarily state it's a more
accurate uh
representation of what they have what
has been described in the first part of
this question yes right and so um
i would say
the
productive
collaboration
is the key that's what makes the system
productive and it's what allows it to
have
to be so productive that it has surplus
right
um
i don't know if i answer the question i
think so
are they
i don't know did you
i'm pretty sure i did i'm sorry i i i
glitched out there for a moment um
really read it again
the setup as i already reread but are
they prosperous are weird countries
prosperous because they are cooperators
or basically do they cooperate because
they're prosperous because they can do
they can they afford to cooperate
because they're prosperous like do we
actually have a causal
uh connection here or uh or is there
as the question asks a feedback loop i
think i think i did answer the question
but i didn't uh connect all the dots
the fact is a purely collaborative
cooperative society is actually really
unproductive right it aspires to be
productive but this is sort of the flaw
in communism is that because it's not
well structured
because it rewards cheaters and punishes
productive people
the amount of cooperation that actually
happens and is useful is low
so it is the dynamism of leveraging
cooperation through a competitive system
that causes the surplus that makes these
systems productive and then it is
self-catalyzing because if that surplus
allows um
for
uh to elaborate the system of
collaboration
of uh cooperation
that's all right
uh sure it's cold out there yeah that's
getting cold
all right
cool question very nice
first question on darkhorsesmissions.com
today
i
what's going on i have no idea yeah i
think
our producer was abducted oh no that's
what it sounded like
oh okay
i have not gotten
question
i have not gotten the coven job but will
be forced to do so to comply with u.s
green card requirements
apologies if this is not the kind of
advice you give and i will of course not
treat any comments you offer as medical
advice this is my hold harmless
declaration if this is what you need
but if you could please offer some
comments on what vaccine appears to be
safest or point me in the direction of
which vaccine to consider slash look
into i would be incredibly grateful
thank you in advance
uh this is a tough question
we are not going to give medical advice
but we can make some observations
um
so if if you need it for u.s green card
you presumably have access to the three
um that americans have had access to
right j
fizer and moderno yeah
now
you can ask the question on two bases
one basis is we have evidence now to a
certain extent about harms that flow
from each of these things and you could
compare those and you could say well
maybe the corrupting force that hides
harm is equally applicable across all of
them and therefore if we compare how
much harm we can see from each the one
that appears harmless might be harmless
i don't think that's a robust logic yeah
but it's possible
and then
i think you would come out somewhere
very different than if you did a first
principles analysis and you said well
which of these things is least likely
to
um
trigger the worst harms for example and
i would say
the
mrna vaccines
wrapped in their lipid nanoparticle
coats
have a couple of unique dangers
that are not applicable to the dna
adenovirus vectored
vaccines and if it were me i would
probably go adenovirus
vaccine
adenovirus vectored vaccine to avoid
lipid nanoparticles introducing
mrna into heart cells that then
transcribe the
transcribe and translate the
the spike protein then causing as we
described here potentially the immune
system to regard those heart cells as
infected by virus and to kill them which
then could weaken and
potentially fatally damage your heart
right i i agree with all of this also
it's only one dose yep um whereas both
the rna vaccines are two doses um and
then uh i agree with everything you've
said and there's a lot more that we
could say
much of which we probably won't hear but
between the two rna vaccines that are
available in the us
moderna is a higher dosage
and
and has a higher rate of adverse events
which is almost certainly linked to just
the the higher amount of of
treatment you're getting um so
uh
that is probably the one that is uh
lowest on the list of of desired
treatments
right and i would finally say
it's possible that there is some
mechanism of introduction that their the
left right arm is better than right arm
or vice versa that um
the butt cheek would be better than the
arm nasal pretty good we don't have that
one but in any case
it is frustrating that we have no
information on
given the very unusual way that the mrna
vaccines
cause the immune the immune system to
become aware of
the antigen
it is terrible that we don't have
information on which introduction method
is most effective
in light of that the adenovirus vectored
one even though the adenovirus vector is
novel in its own way it is at least
entering cells through a biological
logic rather than a
roll of the dice
and
i think that that stands a much better
chance of being at least
controlled rather than arbitrarily
damaging depending on where the stuff
happens to end up in the body
so anyway i don't
i don't like the gamble that they're
trying to get us to take with any of
these things but i like the gamble
better with the uh the dna
versions than the rna
[Music]
okay i'm back
i just realized that i misspoke several
times in the first hour i don't know
yeah i'm not going to tell you how i
know i am um do you want to redo yeah
yeah i want to renew um i kept con i
conflated uh the title of hannah wren's
book which i knew i was doing um
but uh desmond's book is the psychology
of utilitarianism yep not the origins
which i knew that was iran's book anyway
oh well
it's done i almost corrected yeah yeah
but then you're like well she just read
it
yeah i didn't know what the title was i
thought maybe it was a slight play on it
i mean it is it just i got yeah anyway
oh well um i should put that in the show
notes though
speaking of okay the next question
given what dr desmond concluded based on
available history and research and the
ability of mass formation to produce
unity out of a divided and uncertain
population
what do you think the likelihood is that
a mass formation could be triggered on
purpose by government to unify a nation
that has lost its grand narrative while
also being able to both define the new
narrative and simultaneously identify
and purge those that will not unify
around the new narrative and its leaders
just a thought
yeah it's not it's not either or it
doesn't it doesn't have to be one or the
other right and so i think
the idea that
mass formation
could be triggered
intentionally
as opposed to by the kinds of
psychological mechanisms that desmet
spells out very
uh
explicitly as being done for ideology
but not
um
he at least doesn't go to the idea of
controlling people in the way that
you've laid out here but
i certainly don't find it
inconsistent i don't find these
inconsistent explanations
they're completely compatible so i think
the basic answer to your question is
it's totally conceivable that somebody
could do this with intent and
understanding and it's also conceivable
for it to be organic and both probably
happen sometimes yeah yeah totally
sorry i made myself a note um
next question has modern medicine
interfered with evolution by changing
the outcomes of historically deadly
genetic conditions
or is it actually an evolutionary
process itself
both yeah both both um yeah we
definitely absolutely intervene and
cause genes that would drive themselves
to extinction to persist
um but you know you could also say
you know
what fraction of the skills
to feed yourself out in the environment
do you imagine that you obsess and the
answer is
probably not nearly enough to feed
yourself out there so if that's true
then the point is well did
technology that enabled you to forget
those things
make you weaker yeah but it also made
you stronger and that's how the process
works and there i mean
everything
nearly everything that we do that
improves our lives can be understood as
a way of interfering with you know
evolutionary processes that would
otherwise have led us to have
you know perhaps nastier shortish
shorter and
brutish more british lives
um
and that itself is the part of evolution
the fact that we are able to modify our
trajectories in the way that we can yep
um and we've been doing it for a very
long time i'm reminded of this
marvelous
sub-fossil
neanderthal the old man of la chappelle
who was a very old man when he died and
basically had extensive injuries which
had clearly
uh his kin had
basically kept him going you know maybe
he was a
smart interesting guy who knew some
things and you know paid his way based
on wisdom or whatever
but you know the basic point is
uh those things would have taken him out
earlier and the selective process caused
him not to now probably he wouldn't have
left any offspring after the age at
which his decrepitude caught up to him
but
um
i think the larger picture but he may
well have improved the lives of his kin
and thus allowed more of them to survive
longer or you know to the age of
reproduction etc right which is in a
sense why we intervene uh
medically right we come to value each
other and our value isn't
narrow and genetic it is about our
collective capacity and
so anyway it makes evolution
evolutionary sense to do it that you can
certainly make the argument that it
preserves variance that would
otherwise uh go extinct yeah
you called the drink you made for me the
man under board yes
am i supposed to be
working on what that means
well it is a play on man overboard that
much i got right and i thought before
throwing out that title and saying no
not good enough i thought given the
metaphor of drinking a person under the
table a table which is frequently made
of boards oh that a man underboard oh
wow i mean it's a good drink but you
know it's i've got a tolerance enough
that that's not going to send me under a
table no not one of them yeah certainly
not one of them uh it depends on the
effect of the barbecue sauce actually
sorry it is testament to your culinary
skills that i cannot detect the barbecue
sauce at all except when you utter it
from your lips yes there is no barbecue
i mean we have barbecue sauce i noticed
it that's probably why it was on my mind
to mention it as an ingredient but um
no there's none in there i think the um
the texture
would be somewhat different how do you
in fact include barbecue sauce i think
almost any amount of barbecue sauce
would be detectable yeah i do too
next question i drink lots of water
given the ubiquity of glyphosate and
microplastics i guess i ingest them
proportionally thoughts
other examples when apparently healthy
action might be harmful
yeah we are
we cannot escape some of this at this
point without um
leaving the modern world entirely and
even so you know the the scope of a lot
of what we've done is is global at this
point um they're they're
trying to think i can't remember
i guess we inferred
uh that we thought that the visible
insect die-off in the amazon between the
last time we were there in january 2020
and the previous time which had been
march 2016 i guess something like that
so four years um
was likely about
uh dispersed effects of like
neonicotinoid which i'm probably
mispronouncing um yeah nicotinamide
there's no m
well there is the way i say
no you're right
neonicotinoid yeah that's it um
insecticides that are not used there
because there's no farming that happens
anywhere close to the particular very
deep in the amazon and the ecuadorian
amazon place where we were um but that
it's it's coming downstream uh in the
water and possibly even wafting due to
yeah i mean it can't help in the andes
yeah i mean you know you got the andes
on the far western side of the amazon
basin and the basic point is there are
people farming the andes and the
foothills right below them and so
basically anything that gets released up
there
ultimately works its way
uh into
the atlantic
and
um
the question really is you know
comparing the rate of how quickly it
moves and how quickly it degrades to be
biologically
not harmful and the answer is
unfortunately these things degrade too
slowly right very much so
um so
yeah you know are you getting glyphosate
and microplastics and you know estrogens
and other
bioactive molecules
uh in your water if you live almost
anywhere on earth but certainly in the
weird world
yep filters take care of some of that
stuff uh i don't remember at the moment
i have at various points looked to see
you know where's filter technology in
terms of getting rid of things of course
um simply filtering everything out of
your water is a little bit like uh just
you know clearing your gut by taking a
bunch of antibiotics and then assuming
that's fine what you don't want is
totally you know
you don't want to drink water that's
only made up of hydrogen and oxygen it's
not it doesn't taste good it's not good
for you yeah
um so let me let me give you an example
of a place where i ponder over what the
right model is
um that's similar to what the one you're
pondering
if i'm driving someplace how empty does
a highway have to be before i want the
vent
open
right
you know your car there's off gassing of
the materials that the car is made out
of
that
that decreases over time but it is
substantial
fresh air is good for you
so the question is every car on the
highway is putting out exhaust
we live in oregon we have very stringent
uh emissions requirements which i think
are fantastic i have to tell you we
moved from the state of washington where
we didn't have them and the number of
times in washington that you find
yourself behind some vehicle spewing
black smoke that you can't avoid is high
and it happens much less frequently here
so it's true actually i hadn't really
known i hadn't occurred to me to notice
you notice when you're behind those
vehicles yeah in washington
you don't get it in california and you
don't get it in oregon and it's worth it
you know it's a place where government
regulation makes a hell of a lot of
sense even if it's not
particularly well implemented but um
but it works
but anyway the point is
exhaust
carries
does harm
there are harms here which i know
haven't been well enough studied like
um we
motor oil
is a refined version of a crude oil that
crude oil contains a huge range of
organic compounds because basically what
you've got is peep bogs from an ancient
world that have broken down into every
possible fragment of the molecules
so you get basically a slurry
of
carbon compounds it's hugely there's a
huge variety in there and so when you
put oil in your car some fraction of it
gets burned up in the cylinders and
comes out the tailpipe we have catalytic
converters to get
some of the worst defenders out of the
exhaust and the exhaust is pretty clean
because we have engines that burn pretty
clean but the point is you do burn a
certain amount of motor oil
as you run your car
what is the effect of synthetic motor
oil
on people's respiratory health do we
know has anybody even thought to ask the
question no
right and if we have asked the question
maybe we asked it a little bit but i
don't think what we've done is
followed people for decades the r d on
synthetic motor oil was guaranteed to be
almost entirely if not entirely about
its efficacy in the car
which is great which we would need to
know that right but it makes cars last
longer so it's a positive in many
regards but what is its effect on health
as you burn it in your engine i don't
think we know i've been very surprised i
have not been looking but um so anyway
i don't know
when you do get
a burst of exhaust before you manage to
find the vent button in the car you
happen to be driving right
the obvious right thing to do is to vent
the car as quickly as you can so
sometimes i drive like a maniac and get
around the person who's
spit out that huge amount of smoke in
front of me is that the reason and then
i hope it's not the only reason but it
is a reason and then i will open the
windows if i'm on a you know open
stretch of road and that's the obvious
right thing to do but okay suppose
you're not in that situation suppose you
can't get around the person who's just
built smoke and it took you too long to
find the vent button and so you've got
smoke in the car and you're smelling the
exhaust
and now you close the van
22 yeah do you close the van and
is breathing shallowly better for you or
are you holding what you got in your
lung it's a complex question and i don't
know the answer to it i i have guesses
here and there but um but you would
think somebody would have run you
through this logic once just like they
run you through the logic of
you know where the microbes might be
that you would pick up that you would
then wipe into your eyes that would
cause you to get the flu or something
you would think somebody would have run
you through here's the hazard of exhaust
and here's how you reduce that hazard to
you based on these five scenarios or
something but yeah now and the microbes
question like okay microbes from
a kitchen floor a bathroom floor a
toilet seat a kitchen sink a bathroom
sink
a
bed pillow yeah yeah like these are very
different environments yep and they're
going to have
different
communities if you will yes of of of
bacteria and other microbes in them
all right
yeah and i said flu which is obviously a
virus which i don't know if we ever say
viruses or microbes but you know what i
mean microscopic pathway yeah i mean
isn't microbe exactly the sort of like
that's tiny and it can hurt and it's
it's single-celled sort of category i
mean it's not a phylogenetic category
right but i'm i'm thinking our
detractors will
will go after me for saying microbe when
i mean virus because viruses aren't even
single celled and you know you know what
they'll do you know them
you've been counting them yes
due to declining soil conditions and
increased use of chemical fertilizers
and herbicides do you think one day we
won't be able to grow food with enough
nutrition to keep us healthy
we're certainly we are
we certainly are already growing produce
in many parts of
i know the us the best in many parts of
the country that used to have incredibly
rich soil
um that
uh that the food that is grown in those
soils now uh unless they have a lot of
things added to them uh are
much more depopperate with regard to
nutrients so um
you know why why were like iowa's soils
so so rich
um i think it's because that was an
ancient floodplain it was an ancient
alluvial plane
and so it was just like you know flood
after flood after flood of deposition of
you know fine
fine nutrients that uh you know it
doesn't
it takes a lot longer to lay that stuff
down by natural geological and
hydrological processes than it does to
um pull them out in the form of you know
corn and tomatoes
well
we do everything wrong right we we take
the uh
we take all of the byproducts off of the
land we then reintroduce the nutrients
necessary to make the plants grow
um
basically as a product as an
agricultural product we you know in a
bad soil you're effectively growing
hydroponically and then you use inputs
to get the foods to grow and then even
worse
we select for crops
that are
um
profitable
uh so you know super crops for example
uh which give a high yield but are
absolutely utterly dependent on soil
inputs
um so anyway our our industrial process
is absolutely for like at least five
different reasons
reducing the nutritional content you
know a broccoli isn't a broccoli yeah um
and but i mean part and part of it is
also um you know the style of
agriculture
monoculture uh as opposed to
uh more traditional styles of
agriculture in which you're do you know
you're intercropping um but
intercropping can't be harvested by
combine right right and uh once you know
you're talking about tropical soils um
tropics are different because the
the nutrient load lives uh in the
temperate zone in the soils and it tends
to live in in the vegetation in the
tropics um the soils themselves are
generally incredibly impoverished and so
um you know sweden slash and burn
agriculture is actually a very fine way
of doing agriculture on very poor
tropical soils like in the amazon uh but
only at that small pipe at low
population densities and it requires
that you move regularly because yeah
because you know you have a small you
have a small plot and you grow on it and
so what you do is you know you go in and
you you slash
slash vegetation get rid of the woody
stuff and then you basically slow burn
uh the the remaining things in place and
you till that into the soil so that all
the nutrients
uh that were in the plants are now in
the soil and you can then grow your
crops in that for depending on exactly
what was growing there and what you're
planning there you know two three four
five years uh but at some point after
that uh you're not going to be getting
any yield anymore so you go to the next
you know you pick another spot one over
and then you let everything grow back
and so you know if you do this and you
have say just making up numbers here you
know i'm rotating six six crops not six
crops six six sites where you're growing
um a you also grow you know more than
one thing in a place and you may mix it
up year to year as well
but if you're growing on each plot
for five years and you've got six plots
and each of the plots has at least one
preferably two
uh edges that have intact forest next to
it that intact forest basically seeds uh
the the site so that it will start
regrowing as soon as you're not actively
competing against the new growth so give
it 30 years you know six plots five
years each you come back to your first
plot and you've got a lot of secondary
growth on that that you can then
slash and burn yeah and that you know
that's that works but that doesn't feed
a ton of people and you also need a lot
of intact forest around in order to
reseed the plots yep but the important
thing is the the plots thicken even when
you're not there yeah they really do
yeah yeah
you even got your your producer son yeah
i've heard it
yeah the dog
nope noticed yeah that's because you
frisbeed all the all the all the
groaning out of her
could you please discuss myers
berlinskis and gallertner's critiques of
evolution specifically combinatorial
inflation i haven't found a comforting
rebuttal
and then there's a youtube link that i
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um i would
actually love to um
so just give a little just give me a try
i can't i can't i will have to go back
and look at i thought about having them
on the podcast and actually talking
about i actually meant the human
background like you know these guys yeah
i do know these guys um
they are
wrong um it will not surprise any of
them to hear me say that
uh i like them all and i like the way
they're thinking and i think it's useful
to you know to
push us evolutionists around with this
kind of thing
um
but i would have to go back to the
particular argument i remember thinking
it through figuring out where i thought
the errors were and all of that but i
couldn't do it off the top of my head
yep sure would have to go back to it
i
either this is a um
a neologism i don't know or is a typo
um
do you have glasses can you oh yes i do
yeah um
the question reads it's the top one oh
you mean binoculars
top one
m in iso with verona
and then eso with the rona you know what
that means
i know what the rona is yes uh iso iso
it's not it's not capitalized it's not
acronymed okay
this this you know zach
isolation
in my isolation with the rona yes thank
you good
had pain in an old shoulder injury
before other symptoms and heard many
others have had this too
why would this
that's interesting i haven't heard that
before
yeah that's interesting
um
i don't know um our run-in with with the
rona as it were
left me with a lot of thoughts about
the
i assume it is the spike protein lodging
places yeah causing inflammation which
you can imagine if you if your body has
settled into a
fixed functional state but not a
completely repaired state
but that you're talking sort of after
like i'm surprised that you might feel
that he might feel
uh like inflammation from
maybe spike protein in an old injury
like old injury okay so it's not totally
you know it's
that would be a place where such a thing
might stick
like the wear of it doesn't surprise me
so much but why first like why would you
why
would we expect or why do we think it
might have happened that um that would
be the first symptom as opposed to the
other more standard symptoms
i don't
have anything at the top of my head on
that
yeah i mean all i can say is if you've
got some latent thing
uh
that may be sensitive but below some
threshold where you don't detect it i
mean especially old injury you know you
are almost certain to go through a
process
where you have damage that causes pain
and then your body makes some kind of
assessment about this pain is not useful
and so you're not going to feel it
because it doesn't alter your behavior
usefully yeah but you're hovering you
know the point is the pain can be
revealed pretty easily because the
damage is there
yeah your body may need to be like don't
stop
do that
yeah
no that actually that actually makes
sense that you know given given what
pain is and how you know i've got i've
got a couple things lately clearly you
know from the boat accident now
six years ago
actually as of this last week um
which
like oh yeah i can do a lot of stuff and
not notice it and then it'll be you know
something i don't even know what set it
off and like
three days and i'm feeling that thing
which started on you know march 30th
2016.
um
and
i wonder
if at some point if we all get out of
this
that you know the smart scientists in
the future will look back on this on the
smart part of the scientific era and say
yeah you guys were pointing to
inflammation too much like it was it
became like the go-to explanation for so
many things
but it does feel like at the moment
um
to us to both of us and to a lot of
other other people who thought about it
carefully um
uh
our modern lives uh including especially
the drugs that we take and the food that
we eat and the movement that we mostly
don't engage in
um have created sort of an epidemic of
inflammation that's out of whack with
what our bodies need
in both directions but mostly that we
tend to be too inflamed yeah i'm a
strong believer in this based on what i
went through with
wheat yeah basically the only thing
maybe it's not inflammation maybe
there's some other generalized condition
that doesn't have a name right but
a model in which
i was having repeated encounters like
everyday encounters
with a molecule that triggered inflation
and inflation was itself a positive
feedback inflammation
yeah that's late um
i mean i i
said that matthias desmond who seems
great had written
rats and wren's classic book so you know
we're both there yeah today yeah um
anyway
you had multiple daily
multiple daily run-ins with a molecule
that you now know was causing you
inflammation and maybe causes all of us
inflammation was precisely causing
inflammation significant inflammation
and inflammation is a positive feedback
yeah and so the point was once that
thing that doesn't take and i now know
because it takes so little weight to
trigger me
that tiny amount of this can put me in a
phase where all of the symptoms i used
to have come back and it takes you know
careful diligence to get out of that and
so you know how perfect is that model
how specific is it not perfect and
probably not specific enough but my
senses is generally right yup
um yeah
yep but i like the idea that there will
be smart scientists in the future a it
suggests that there will be a future
and b
smart scientists in it you know i mean
if there's going to be a future we're
definitely going to want those we
definitely want that future yeah yeah
compare the size of world war ii
soldiers with soldiers of today
what is the limit of that growth i think
it's that they're getting bigger
i think well i had some very small green
plastic
is that not what we're talking about
the question
continues does it now it does
except it's got a lot of
dashes and strange punctuation so um
compare the size of world war ii
soldiers versus the soldiers of today
what is the limit of that growth with
increasing access to food could giants
have evolved this way did they rule the
smalls ah
um
well welcome to
allomatry
so yeah
okay
so the issue is this there's certain
things that you can scale up
indefinitely and then there are other
things that you can't and uh let me see
if i can recover my go-to example here
isometric yes pi does not
yeah
[Laughter]
right because pie gets frankly less
appealing pie gets less appealing the
bigger it's harder to cook because you
cook the outside too much and the inside
hasn't begun yeah i like the cooking
it's hard to eat
well there's that i mean
i mean pie is appealing because it's you
know triangular you can kind of
man
what i don't know peeling pie just it
doesn't seem like okay that's spelled
differently
yeah i guess it would be um
the point
is
the uh
here's the example i'm looking for
the
surface to volume ratio
of
a
sphere
versus the
diameter to circumference ratio of a
circle
the diameter to circumference ratio
of a circle is invariant it doesn't
matter how big the circle is
therefore isometric right the surface to
volume ratio of a sphere
varies
radically as the sphere grows the
surface-to-volume ratio goes down which
is why which is an example of elementary
allometry which is why electric changes
you why the cells in the mouse are
approximately the same size as the cells
in the whale is that there's an upper
limit to how big you can make a cell and
get enough oxygen into it and so that
limit is found by all creatures and our
cells are the same size so anyway the
point is
the allometric relationships
in the structure of a person
mean that you can't scale it up
indefinitely
so
you neither see moused moused that's not
a word
mouse-sized elephants
nor elephant-sized mice
and this and this isn't a question of
well back in the day there were giant
nicely like they were giant sauce no
right like mice
um with their very thin long bones um
aren't wouldn't be able to withstand the
effects of gravity um at if they were
the size of an elephant and so elephants
um don't have a great deal of like
flexibility because what they have is
these like giant trunk like long bones
that they that they are on like this
um and that don't offer much you know if
someone takes a chop at them parallel to
the ground uh those bones might well
break but they have tremendous um
strength in the in the in the direction
that's parallel to the bone right and
actually the perfect way to see this is
dogs because we have tried to do
everything to them selectively that's
true and the point is we have gone
down in
size and stature very effectively with
dogs i mean if you think the ancestor is
a wolf and a chihuahua or whatever is
even smaller than that we've been very
effective at making diminutive dogs that
miniature dutch spice hand that we saw
earlier was amazing
yeah he was a
he was a very flavorful little pup but
anyway
the point is we have we can shrink down
a dog from wolf size
really well not an individual dog no no
no no that wouldn't work but um
but
in terms of going the other direction we
have made some large dogs that are
bigger than wolf but we haven't gone
nearly as far in the up direction as the
down direction
and the dogs that are really large all
suffer from these deficiencies because
the structure of wolf is not as you
build it up gangly they end up with hip
dysplasia yeah
you create problems so anyway the point
is
you can and in fact hmm
hobbits yeah um
you know so you asked about soldiers you
get spheres
elephants and hobbits yeah that's what
you get spheres in circles
what's that
dog dogs oh sir sure i forgot about that
but that seems more in keeping with
soldiers somehow yes
well lots of soldiers have dogs i mean
they come home to them yeah and very few
i suppose some of them probably have
spheres
very few of them have elephants
many of them have overcome their spheres
in order to do the soldiers in order to
do the work yeah sure
but the point happens
you've only had half a drink this isn't
enough it's the time of day yeah it's
been a long time
hobbits homo for us sciences exactly yes
uh the flores island all right uh in
eastern indonesia we're gonna cut this
short but there are these these um
[Music]
sub fossil human or hominid
like 30 40 000 years creatures yes
um
i'm trying to remember the is it
13 000 years sticks in my mind but it
may be 30. um but in any case we've got
these sub fossil that is to say not turn
to stone actual bone remains
on the island of flores yeah i'm closer
to right in indonesia
and i think the idea was that the
population may have lasted until
13. i can't remember what the evidence
well wikipedia is a flaming dumpster
fire which of course you would expect it
to be if it's a dumpster flower but not
flaming that's why steaming
dumpster fire of
anyway it's suggested until 50 000 years
ago at which point um homo sapiens
arrived 55 0.
all right so but i don't know clearly i
should remember this story better but
the point was
you had a population people have argued
about whether this population was
pathological or whatever there are lots
of nonsense arguments but it is clearly
a diminutive
uh race of hominids that lived on flores
island
hunting pygmy elephants in fact pygmy
stegadon elephants
and
the point is uh
they were very likely wiped out by
full-size uh hominids who arrived later
having been dwarfed by their presence on
flores
okay so the point is does the
um
does the basic premise of your
story that bigger humans could wipe out
smaller humans stand yes it does
but there is a limit you can't just
scale humans up to wipe out other humans
because you make humans worse at being
humans as they get above a certain size
so there are limits to that process
and it's more expensive to to be a human
and to make a human and you know if you
live in a place of at all marginal
uh resource capacity uh it's gonna be
harder to maintain a population that has
the same number but has a larger mass
yup
hello
have you considered the evolution of
mental illness do you believe it is
linear moving through generations or
bound to the individual
um
look it's clearly there are heritable
defects but more often than not i would
say you're dealing you may have a
propensity but that propensity may not
even be what you think it may not be a
gene that makes you vulnerable it may be
a gene that provides some characteristic
the downside of which is a vulnerability
but mental illness is going to be
overwhelmingly the
developmental result of a mismatch
between environments and
um people
i mean we talked a little bit in our
book about ways that that could happen
but
um like
so many other things that is function in
our eyes the dysfunction in our jaws
the dysfunction of our minds
is
about hyper novelty not 100 but in large
measure
that's right
next question
are do you have must reads
for a true understanding of evolution i
have read hunter-gatherer's guide and
selfish gene where would you go next
it really depends on what aspect of
evolution you're interested in
that's what we do if you've read this
you know this already but the
recommended further reading at the end
of the book
um
ancestors tale dawkins is fabulous in
terms of a deep history
um your inner fish
does the anp brilliantly that's shuben
that's neil shub in 2008
your inner fish journey into the 3.5
billion year history of the human body
similarly um i don't know that i that we
included it here but uh the evolution of
the oh no it is here lieberman daniel
lieberman the story of the human body
evolution health and disease
beautiful book
guns germs and steel guns germs and
steel understand
uh big patterns of history i would also
suggest on the same front peter turchen
um
he's
marvelous and i think largely
in the right the right spot i mean all
of these really i mean guns germs and
steel is on the list too behave by
sapolsky anything by zapolsky
um and then i guess um
two of the books that i always highly
recommend if this is in the in the area
of evolution that you're interested in
are mother nature by sarah blah for
hurting uh which is um and then um
baboon metaphysics by cheney and
seyfarth mother nature being sort of
about the evolution of sociality and
relationship um told through a female
lens ish and um social evolution and uh
and it's about social evolution as well
and i was gonna suggest social evolution
if you wanna i'm not done talking about
the two books i was just mentioning
though um so it was mother nature and
baboon metaphysics which is about the
evolution of theory of mind and you know
the one
one other thing one of the areas that i
see um
really smart people who are thinking in
sort of similar spheres that we are but
don't have a background in non-human
organisms
is that they that many people like to
draw a very hard and fast line around
like humans are conscious humans
have nuance in their decision making
humans
uh understand that there's an other out
there and uh baboon metaphysics is just
an extraordinary book to break you of
those that kind of thinking if you
really think that it's like
and then humans came and we just started
doing all the stuff like well that that
wouldn't be the case of course uh if you
imagine us to be evolved um and
the baboons which happens to be the
subject of of this book
but they but they look at evidence and
you know in crows and in toothed whales
like dolphins um other things other
organisms as well
for having theory of mind for being able
to imagine that what is known by the
other whom you're interacting with is
not the same that you yourself know
is
really important for us to
figure out what it is
that we are um
that we are doing in the world and if
you could hear that you could you could
probably infer that uh fairfax
um may have more theory of mind than
most cats but he does not have theory of
windowsill
i think he just doesn't care what we
think he just doesn't give a [ __ ] yes
yeah that's pretty much uh so social
evolution by trippers bob trevor so
it's excellent but it's it's a textbook
yeah but it's it's an accessible
textbook and it would give you a deep
window into
the the social side of evolution yep um
and i would also recommend
robert wright's non-zero
yeah i think that's i think we put that
in there as well yep
okay
um
as a paramedic
facts injured and a fan i want to say
thanks for everything you do
thank you
yeah thank you and uh
that's a terrible
terrible thing that has befallen you i
feel terrible about it yeah
okay it's we got 50 more minutes let's
see um
we just had our first kid in november
learning curve is steep from an
evolutionary standpoint why do babies
fight sleep harder the more tired they
become
seems counterproductive
you know i've i don't know that we
experienced that with our with our boys
um
you tell me if you remember that i don't
particularly remember that but i
certainly heard it from other people
who i think were
you know being
you know
spending a lot of time with their babies
and you know and and had hands on a lot
and were you know breastfeeding and all
of this so i don't i you know i think in
this regard perhaps we just got lucky um
but i will i would preface an answer
with
i've heard this happens but i don't know
it to be true so in this case the
premise is a
i'm not totally sure of it but well okay
i'm gonna take a guess here okay we do
lots of things some of them we don't
really have any choice about right now
it turns out
that this whole diaper thing is insane
no matter what version of it you do
why is it insane
because if you look at cultures
that are
not technological
they have a mechanism for dealing with
this and it involves communication
between mother and offspring that starts
from day one in which the mother very
quickly intuits when the baby has to
engage in one of these functions
points the baby in the right direction
and it all works out and you don't end
up you know frankly
taping the poop to the baby which is
just dumb right
um
some babies seem to like i don't know a
one that does but
um
but the point is we don't have this you
can't do this in a world of sidewalks
and elevators and cars and i mean some
people do we sort of
we didn't i don't think you yeah so i i
i want to see the person who actually
pulls it off in an urban landscape sleep
training without diapers you know in
among uh
for a while being without
diapers at all is the right thing to do
i didn't mean sleep training i mean
potty training yeah yeah it's the right
thing to do from the point of view of
the child's development because what we
do is we cause the child to lose touch
with their control
and then they have to regain that
control later which is often traumatic
and weird
but never losing that control in the
first place would be the obvious way to
go it's what our ancestors did and
modern
life doesn't allow it so we do something
else and it sucks
um
there's a lot of that and my point about
the sleep thing would be
there's better and worse with respect to
what we do with respect to sleep right
the old i i hope i'm uh convicting the
right guy but dr spock kind of advice
um
about you know
you're toughening your kid up by put
them in a room let them scream let them
scream right that's a bunch of [ __ ]
make sure you don't touch them
right and you know the previous advice
definitely don't cuddle that baby you
know yeah don't you don't want to over
love your kids you'll you'll you know
destroy them psychologically this is all
nonsense you're programmed to know to
love your kids and to get angry at them
when you're supposed to and stuff like
that and that goes wrong in some people
but in general the point is
your instincts are about right and to
the extent that your child crying
because you put them asleep alone
somewhere is you know hard for you to
endure and you want to go
bring them to you that's an ancient
instinct trying to get you to do the
right thing
point being if there's anything whether
you can do anything about it or not if
there's anything about the child's sleep
environment
that doesn't fit with the child's
understanding of how the world is
supposed to work
then the point is fighting sleep is a
way to get that thing not to happen
right like if going to bed is terrifying
i don't want to go to bed right their
anxiety may be unfounded but they may
have no way of knowing that right right
so you know you may you may have created
a
utterly amazing and wonderful home for
them but if you put them down alone
where there's no warm mom or dad or
sibling or whatever to you know to to
cuddle with and to know that there is
safety there then waking up in such an
environment may induce fear now that's
you know that's different from not going
to sleep in the first place but it might
be related right but the idea is if
there's anything about the environment
that to the child is negative then the
idea of as sleep begins to take your
choice away from you
fighting harder because you feel
yourself losing the battle
makes sense
yeah
um so i mean congratulations and it's
congratulations we should have started
there
it's just marvelous and miraculous and
every every part of parenthood is
um unexpected and
and wonderful and
um
somehow just keep saying better
yeah not every part of it is wonderful i
totally expected school to suck and it
did
for them yeah
i saw that coming it's not parenthood i
mean
i didn't say every part of their lives
is wonderful yeah
i mean in this world you think i'm
arguing that everything that they engage
in is fabulous no
no
i don't think you've said that but i see
interacting with their schools as
part of the parenthood thing
yeah well that's um
that's a story for when they're done
with those schools
yeah very wise
i know that you both try to live
organically with regard to food medicine
cleaning etc can you think of any
examples in which a synthetic is better
than its natural equivalent
that's a great question yeah
and i i i suspect just off the top i
suspect that the answer is well i
suspect that there are answers but i
can't think of any right now
um
i will have a long list of them
approximately a half an hour after the
podcast ends
yes there are there are superior
um
well i mean so things like
adhesives
yep
uh you know i
uh
so in largely i mean this is not a fancy
thing but we have some beautiful pieces
of wood furniture uh that are
oil finished that we you know
clean with water and then oil uh with uh
with
with
with natural oils in order to keep clean
and the idea of putting a shellac of
some sort of urethane on those things is
is anathema
however
if the what you're trying to do on the
surface is
uh you know carpentry or
uh butchering
uh you might
well benefit from such a surface
yep unfortunately in those cases
i would make a strong argument the other
way
because of the danger of picking up the
synthetic in the food
it
i can't believe we're being thrown by
this because there are
places where these synthetics have
uh
real advantages they are limited but i
think adhesives is a big one there's not
there's not that much
uh you know resins you know we've all
gotten stuck with resins with like uh
you know gums from trees or cut slugs
you know like i i didn't need those
things to stick together um
but obviously
uh epoxies and um
uh what what are you using all the time
nozzex
santa acrylates yeah are um
and just even just white glues like you
know lots of different adhesives for
lots of different uh applications
uh are are
i think better than almost anything that
we can find in nature i'm i'm
remembering okay good um let's take
i love to rail against
carbon fiber in bicycles
right
it's a terrible material for a bicycle
it solves one huge problem
and that one huge problem is that it is
readily possible to build a bike that
will last you for your entire life out
of steel which is bad for the bicycle
industry so they've solved the problem
by making plastic bicycles that have a
shelf life and that that is to say it's
not a problem for the bicyclist right
however
it doesn't rust though
no it's it's got you have to do some
maintenance on the steel brakes got some
great characteristics okay
doesn't rust you don't need to paint it
um it's truly light you know it's dry
it's truly strong in the anticipated
direction but you can build with that in
mind
can you do they have like are they cross
fibered now at this point so that
they're strong
and you can make shapes with carbon
fiber that you can't readily make you
could
you could do it in some way with with
metal but it would be very difficult
there are ways it's much easier to make
but at the same time that i really
detest carbon fiber as a bicycle
material because frankly when it fails
fails catastrophically and it can kill
you right your bicycle can disintegrate
out from under you which is something a
steel bike wouldn't do
right a steel bike could fail
but it would fail gradually slowly it
would creak you'd get warning it
wouldn't just collapse you know a carbon
fiber bicycle wheel can explode right
but
if i'm going to take a tripod into the
amazon i want a carbon fiber tripod
right the strength to weight ratio is
good the resistance to corrosion
whatever herd of peccaries comes at it
laterally
takes it out
right
but the point is carbon fiber has its
place in my opinion it is not on
bicycles that's not to say there's no
part on a bicycle that i would make out
of it but there's almost no part that i
would want to depend on i wouldn't do a
handlebar i wouldn't do a wheel i
wouldn't do a spoke i wouldn't do a
frame right no i actually think and you
and i come out in different places on
this but um
like i for some number of years doing
tropical field work uh assumed that
these fancy wicking synthetic
fibers were the thing that i would want
and after a couple of years of just
stinking to high heaven and not being
able to get the smell out of them i went
i went to wool so i wear i wear wool
tank tops with like men's over shirts to
deal with the mosquitoes when i'm in the
field in the tropics and i just like
love the wool i think i think wool is
exactly right for me
um you wear the synthetic shirts and i
also wear the quick dry pants
so you know certainly for pants
um at least for some um for some
environments for tropical environments
where you don't want to keep it on the
inside the the you know you it's you're
gonna get wet because it's going to rain
and you're also going to sweat and you
want something that's just going to
breathe and cotton once it gets wet
stays wet wool once it gets wet um
it stays wet all the natural smells like
a sheep but that's okay all the natural
fibers literally wet
right right whereas a nylon fiber water
doesn't get into it so the fiber may get
wet but it dries out readily because the
water hasn't gotten into it yeah you
know like painting a paintbrush yeah um
so yeah that's another great case yeah
they're quite i don't even know like
what the material exactly is what
but the quick dry pants like the ex
officio yeah
plastic fiber yeah and someone like the
for me like the outdoor research
gore-tex hat uh
but you know in that case you've got a
great hat that you know people think is
an affectation but it's a hundred
percent not you've got a leather hat oh
the leather hat is fabulous
but it's not crushable
you can't it's easy it's not crushable
but you know you can to the extent it
loses some of its waterproofness you can
waterproof it with avocado oil from the
kitchen right so it's got that advantage
it's wet giving away all the secrets now
i am giving away the secret that is to
me who was wondering where all the
avocado oil had gone in the field
you just said in the kitchen right there
are field kitchens
everywhere we go yep
no it works with canola oil yes that's
what unfortunately the field kitchens
have is the nasty seed oils yes but yeah
okay so i would go with the leather hat
for sure the leather hat is great and
people will make fun of you but um
it's the right material for the hat
the synthetic pants
definitely carbon fiber in its place
camera stuff
right
camera stuff but i mean there is no
natural equivalent well there is camera
lenses used to be all metal and i must
say i was not a huge fan wait what are
you talking about well the lenses were
obviously glass but the bodies were
metal
and these things so the lenses were
metal yeah camera lenses the bodies of
the lenses were metal okay and that's
and that was a problem because it's
heavy just heavy just wait it's heavy
and it also does it wicks more as well
like is it more likely yeah you could
get it condensation sensation issues um
but camera lenses have come a long way
at the same time they've moved in the
direction of a lot more plastic and you
know the cheapo lenses are all plastic
except for the glass
but
the
really top quality lenses almost all of
them include a significant amount of
plastic and the truth is if you had a
choice you'd probably want the ones that
had a significant amount of plastic
because frankly you can carry a larger
kit of lenses
if that's what it's made out of um you
know it's good stuff
yeah
anyway yeah there is a long list but one
has to be
quite judicious about it because you do
tend to give something up but especially
if there's a lot of pressure to do
something right even if the initial
plastic version of something sucks badly
eventually they'll get to a version
that's pretty elegant yeah so here's
here's another thing i actually i
actually think
if we were like okay we're going to sit
here and have a couple more drinks and
you know riff on this for an hour which
we're not going to do we come up with a
lot more examples but one more thing
that comes up for me is um
watercraft
where um
i have known and been on some utterly
gorgeous wooden boats like so beautiful
and i also
in at least one of those cases two of
those cases i guess have known the
owners and known
how many hundreds of hours they put into
those boats every single year yep right
and i have seen
on um sometimes in the water and on cars
driving away from the water wooden
kayaks
gorgeous i assume the same amount of
upkeep
and um now that in the last
year and a half
i have begun paddle boarding notice that
occasionally and in fact
i've seen you know there are some you
know beautiful wooden wooden boards out
there
um
probably
upkeep and weight
are
the reasons you know i have i have a
not aesthetically attractive at all
inflatable paddle board
that
i can get on top of and down from the
top of the car any time i want to i i am
relying on no one else anytime i want to
put my board in the water excuse me and
i think it's actually going to be warm
enough this week that i may do so for
the first time this this year um so i've
actually been thinking about this i saw
two people on the river on paddle boards
today
water temperatures still right around 50
so it's a little a little cold but um
the weight alone yep right like i i
would love also to have been sometimes
kayaking on my own not that i wanted to
do it on my own but like oh i want to go
when i maybe today i'd like to be in a
kayak right on the paddle board i can't
wrangle and we don't have wooden kayaks
but we have fiberglass kayaks
and um
it's just too heavy it's just too heavy
and unwieldy for me
to do it on my own uh whereas uh
whereas the synthetic gives you that
additional well the quality synthetic
yeah and the i know the the kayak story
isn't quite as as clean yeah but this is
this is true actually now that i think
about it across most domains car wise
i you know
in terms of what makes my my heart thump
yes a beautiful classic car that's you
know
all metal rubber yeah wood leather right
yeah that's the car i want to own
it's not the car i want to buy
it's not the car i want to maintain no
it's it's the car you want to borrow
you know where you want to drive
where are we infinitely wealthy it's the
car i want to have in the garage because
you send it to the staple to be taken
care of i don't want to be looking at
the plastic dashboard but probably
frankly from the point of view of safety
the economics of it the
maintenance it's the it's a slam dunk
winner yeah you know and then there are
other realms where it's like cameras
where it's like
there are places
for the synthetic stuff and not you know
guns i would point out there's been a
revolution in guns where especially in
handguns
they have moved to what they
euphemistically call polymer which is
plastic
four
parts of the gun that you can do in
plastic
right and then the point is there are
certain parts of the gun that you
wouldn't do in plastic and they're still
metal but that has radically changed
uh guns as it has radically changed
cameras as it has radically changed cars
all of these things and so the thing is
plastic was like a synonym for junk
at the beginning because the plastics
weren't very good they weren't very
tolerant of uv light
but as
polymer chemistry has gotten better and
we've learned our lessons from these
things actually lots of stuff that at
one time you wouldn't have wanted the
plastic version of now it's what you
want right
excellent okay um
oh boy there are a lot more questions
and we've gone an hour and we are um it
is late so i'm just gonna find three
more quickly here and apologies to the a
handful of handfuls
a handful of people whose questions we
don't get to
comment
um
brett you're an awesome man and heather
you are a wonderful adult female human
thank you for not calling her a
menstruator
i'm a i'm a uterus hammer a uterus haver
god damn would you consider interviewing
madia de guerrera
i'm like pronouncing her name correctly
de guerre i never know okay that's how
i've heard you pronounce i think would
you consider interviewing maddie de gray
and divi and diving into what happened
sure
and similarly
in response to the person who asked
about evolutionary mental health would
brett please do an interview with dr k
from healthy gamer as evolutionary
mental health is his wheelhouse i don't
have any idea who that is i don't either
that sounds interesting i would love to
have a proper discussion about the
effect of
games on
mental health yeah yeah so maybe if our
moderator is still still there and
paying attention these two are worth
putting on our ever-growing list of
possible we should point out our
moderator is on the east coast where it
is uh yes so may well not be uh still
with us um
oh god
uh why does my belgian shepherd have the
face of a fruit bat um convergent
cuteness now this is where i should have
introduced the idea of the dutch spice
hound
that we saw earlier so when you say
fruit bat
you probably mean flying foxy probably
mega man coated yeah old world fruit bat
well in which case you know they're
called flying foxes because they look
like dogs
um so fox's being dogs yep it's not that
it's not that far um
you should look into new world fruit
bats which is what i worked on which
look
pretty wild some of them
check out the most of the new world
fruit bats almost all of them
have a fleshy
nose leaf which can be quite elaborate
and actually you don't you won't get it
from a photograph because it looks very
static like it's full of cartilage or
something but it's actually a fleshy
appendage that they can kind of wiggle
around that's
pretty cool
um
man that epic tab he's really yelling i
think he's hungry yeah he may be hungry
um
okay two more quick questions again
apology oh
uh we're not we're not gonna have time
to do this have some fun riff on the
slap at the oscars
was there a slap at the oscars
good
excellent
um if hormonal birth control can change
women's moods pheromones and mate
preferences is exposure to everyday
synthetics altering our choices
uh could well be yes that's a big
question yeah it's a big question that
warrants more answer um
uh but but yeah
yeah i mean
let's say this
one of the things we talk about in our
book
is the fact that smell
used to be not 100 but almost 100
you could smell something and get a
sense for whether it was something
that should appeal to you or repel you
without paying a cost
for doing so
that is no longer true right the smell
of a
fish that's been in the sun
will repel you and there's no harm to
you smelling right the smell of gasoline
is different right you're inhaling
actual gasoline vapor and that will
cross the barrier in your lungs and it
will make it into your body and it will
have some impact which is likely to be
very negative
you know
so the point is
the inhaling of some of these
modern
compounds
may be feminizing for example because
many of these plastic-related and
pesticide-related compounds are
estrogens there are variations on the
estrogen chemistry estrogen mimics or
progenitors right and so the point is
could that have an effect on people
abso-frequently it'll be an arbitrary
effect right um
and who knows
what impact it's having yep
final question
are there plans for you two to re-enter
academia eventually if so where
uh through the skylight
not as such uh there are some
interesting
um alternative
things of higher ed afoot but i don't
think either of us
at this point aim to or will find
ourselves full time in a classroom again
i think that's unlikely that we would we
would do that i will say
i'd be very
much more excited about a blank sheet of
paper about what education should look
like in which case
i and i'm sure we are open
to various possibilities then the idea
of getting back into the academy which
is like you know the more i look at what
it's doing to itself it's like
why would i want to go back there i
don't want to set my children there i
don't want to go back there
it seems like a dumb place to be full of
crazy people
indeed yeah
all right
are we there i think we might be there i
think we're there yeah i think if we do
this long enough zach will not be quite
so there it is yeah see last week we
took him by surprise yeah and that was
not cool uh that was that was not cool
we owe our producer and our son more
respect than that more time more
and um yeah he has now had a week's
worth of warning on being taken by
surprise exactly and uh the extremely
hungry and somewhat damp
epic tabby is uh yes caterpillar has
returned and has not yet turned into a
butterfly
um
so um oh that's he's not visible that's
too bad
yeah
okay
um
well that went terribly that doesn't
work for cats all right
we will see you guys here next
week until then
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
you